make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
today i want to try something a little
bit different uh with king and black
having recently come out and you guys
going absolutely nuts over that video i
thought it'd be a good time to go
over pretty much all the symbiotes in
the marvel universe as well as highlight
some of the hosts of those symbiotes and
when figuring out the best way to do
this
we basically have two options we can go
in the chronological order based on the
date of their first appearance or we can
go in chronological order based on where
in the timeline of the marvel universe
they appeared and i think the second
option will make the most sense as we
progress
throughout the symbiotes and so that's
what we're going to do that means that
we need to start with the very beginning
of the history of the symbiotes and
because that history has been retconned
relatively recently
that means we're going to go with one of
the most recent characters to be
introduced null the god of the symbiotes
so uh for those of you guys who are a
little bit behind here
null was created by donnie cates and
ryan stegman and first appeared in venom
number three
in 2008 with his origin being revealed
in the very next
issue so null is older than the marvel
universe itself existing in a dormant
state
until he was awakened by the celestials
when they began creating the current
iteration of the marvel universe
now anchor that the celestials were
filling the void that he'd ruled null
creates all black the necro sword and
slays one of the celestials with it a
crime for which he's banished back to
the void now null uses this opportunity
to grow more formidable strengthening
the all black sword in a forge that was
made from the head of the dead celestial
all black we would later learn
was the prototype of the race that would
become the symbiotes as we know them
and the fire of the forge and the sound
of knoll's hammer would instill in all
future symbiotes vulnerabilities in both
fire
and sound now null goes on a murderous
rampage across the universe
destroying billions of solar systems in
the process until he stopped by gore the
godbutcher who defeats null and takes
all black from him now in the century
following his defeat
nolt figured out that he could actually
bond his living abyss with lesser
creatures and control them across
galaxies thereby creating the first true
symbiotes now in terms of power
null definitely lives up to his name as
god of the symbiotes because he's
godlike in his power his primary ability
is that he can create weapons and other
symbiotes using the living abyss
not only is he capable of creating
literal armies of symbiotes but he can
also control them through a telepathic
link that he shares with them in
addition to this he's immortal and
possesses superhuman strength and
durability to the point of being
practically invulnerable and the thing
about knowles powers is this i would
wager
that we haven't even come close to
seeing the limits of what he can do
i mean in the most recent issue we saw
him ensnare celestials into his bidding
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
and so i imagine that we're probably
going to see null display
some ridiculous abilities that we didn't
even know that he had now one of the
first symbiotes that knoll created
was the grindel which was also created
by donnie cates and ryan stegman and
first appeared in venom number four now
grindel was one of several symbiotes
that took the form of a dragon and it
was while piloting the grendel symbiote
that null
first learned of earth now as grendel
attacked a village the villagers cried
out for their hero beowulf but were
instead
answered by thor now thor strikes
grindel with a bolt of lightning which
severs knoll's control
over his symbiotes and his vulnerability
to electricity would continue to be a
trait of symbiotes
long into the future the resulting
symbiotes began seeking out new hosts
reproducing and rebelling against null
which is how the race of symbiotes
created by null became the klyntar which
we learn
is their race's word for cage and
imprison their deity now the grindel
symbiote possesses superhuman strength
stamina and durability which are powers
that are common to symbiotes but
grendel's powers are of a much higher
scale than most symbiotes due to him
having such a close connection
with its creator null now the grindel
symbiote is also able to generate
other symbiotes and is also able to
reanimate corpses by bonding them
to its offspring of course the most
popular symbiote and the one introduced
to the marvel universe
is venom the version of venom mostly
familiar with was created by david
miccellini and todd mcfarlane and first
appeared in the amazing spider-man
300 in 1988 but his origins in the
marvel universe go back much further
than that the symbiote that would become
known as venom
was part of the 998th generation of
symbiote offspring and was cast out from
the rest of the symbiotes for being
mentally insane
before being obtained by the cree who
hoped to harness its shape-shifting
abilities in their war with the scrolls
now the symbiote was bonded to a cree
warrior named telcar but was eventually
separated from him and returned to the
cree homeworld before somehow making its
way to battle world
which leads us to the symbiote's
original origin story as told in secret
wars number eight by jim shooter and
mike zech now in that issue of secret
wars which i have the whole story
covered you can find a link to it down
in the description
in the ensuing chaos spider-man's
costume gets ripped up
but luckily the heroes find a machine
that can create any clothing that they
want
spider-man however chooses the wrong
machine and is covered by a black goo
that becomes his new costume kind of a
fun fact here in deadpool's secret
secret war marvel actually changed that
so the deadpool was on battle world
which we didn't know about and he
actually directed spider-man to the
machine itself not realizing that it
actually had a venom symbiote in it and
that's how peter parker basically became
the new venom but it's kind of a small
fun little retcon the story is really
good if you guys ever get a chance it's
a really really really fun story but
regardless spider-man wears this costume
for a while but then he begins to
realize that it was trying to bond to
him permanently and so he leaves it with
a fantastic four
who believe that they have the symbiote
contained of course they don't
and the semi escapes and bonds to peter
once again but parker still rejected it
by exploiting its weakness to sonics and
ringing church bells to drive it away
now a disgraced reporter named eddie
brock would then wander into the church
seeking some sense of direction in his
life the discarded venom symbiote could
tell that eddie harbored hatred for
peter parker who he blamed for his
professional downfall and so the
symbiote bonded with eddie turning him
into venom and brock and the symbiote
joined together in their common mission
to get revenge on peter parker now
venom's powers include superhuman
strength and durability as well as
shape-shifting including the ability to
disguise itself by replicating the
appearance of normal street clothes now
because it's bonded with spider-man the
venom symbiote has inherited his
superpowers
such as the ability to produce and swing
from webs and is also immune to peter
parker's spider sense but eddie
is not the last host of the venom
symbiote and in fact the symbiote has
bonded with several
other individuals and i guess i'm
already going out of order here in terms
of chronology
but since these are all hosts of the
venom simian i figured we'd go ahead and
discuss them all here anyway kind of
makes the most sense
so after the venom symbiote was
separated from eddie it approached
another of spider-man's perennial foes
the scorpion
matt gargan and so what happens is that
norman osborne had been
imprisoned and needed spider-man to
break him out which of course spider-man
would never do
except that under norman osborne's
orders scorpion had kidnapped aunt may
and would only free her
if spider-man helped break norman out of
jail which makes sense now during the
conversation where mack
explains this arrangement to peter peter
makes the remark that scorpion will
always be
a b-list villain specifically saying
it's not like your venom but when mack
goes home
the venom symbiote is waiting for him
and offers to bond with him telling him
that on his own he'll always be a joke
but if he bonds with a symbiote no one
will ever laugh at him again
obviously scorpion takes him up on this
offer or he wouldn't be in this video
and he becomes venom which granted him
all the same powers that eddie brock had
had as venom until the symbiote was
removed from gargan after he was
arrested for his antics as one of the
dark avengers during the dark brain
story now another of venom's notable
hosts was flash thompson a sometimes
rival and sometimes friend of peter
parker who lost his legs in a heroic
sacrifice during the iraq war now with
the u.s government in possession of the
venom symbiote at the time
and the amazing spider-man number 654 by
dan slott they approached flash about
participating in project rebirth 2.0 now
why do they call it that
because the program that turned steve
rogers into captain america was called
project rebirth and the cardinal rule of
marvel comics is that every organization
without exception
wants to replicate the success of that
original program and create their own
super soldier now flash agrees and is
bonded with the symbiote turning him
into agent venom which grants him all
the powers of his favorite hero
spider-man
as well as venom's shape-shifting
abilities and of specific significance
to flash
the venom symbiote would also allow him
to walk again and he would remain bonded
to the venom symbiote from 2011
up until 2016 and so a pretty long time
by modern comic standards
something else to kind of note here
depending on who you talk to a lot of
people
actually liked agent venom more than
they liked eddie brock venom he was
hugely popular when he first came out
people loved him people loved the story
of asian venom i feel like we should
cover it let me know down in the
comments section if you guys want me to
cover agent venom i don't know if you
guys want me to or not i feel like it'd
be kind of interesting but before we get
into the offspring of the venom symbiote
something that i do want to point out
here is that there are
several more hosts of the venom symbiote
over the years in both the main marvel
continuity and even in alternate
realities for example
in the old man logan universe which
basically imagines the marvel universe
as a desolate post-apocalyptic
wasteland we see the venom symbiote had
actually bonded to a literal t-rex in
wolverine number 69 by mark miller and
steve mcniven now this version seems to
basically be identical to the symbiote
of the 616 universe so we can assume
that this venomous rex venom
venomosaurus rex
this i like venomous rex uh just has the
normal venom powers and abilities
uh on earth 65 the numerical designation
of the universe where gwen stacy became
spider-gwen there is a version of venom
that was created by a scientist named
elsa brock in an attempt to find a cure
for the lizard formula that had turned
that universe's peter parker
into the lizard first appearing in
spider-gwen number 19 by jason letour
and robbie rodriguez the venom of earth
65
is not an alien symbiote but is
artificially created by a reaction
between the radioactive spider isotopes
that gave gwyn her powers and the lizard
formula now gwen would later bond with
the symbiote to become gwynem and
spider-gwen number 24.
the venom symbiote grants its wear all
the powers that spider-gwen had
which are essentially the same as the
spider-man of earth 616 but it also must
have
a compatible host as it will kill
incompatible ones through the radiation
from the spider isotopes furthermore the
symbiote makes its wear subject to
overly aggressive behavior by removing
their inhibitions and amplifying their
emotions and so this version of the
symbiote also retains the weaknesses to
heat and sonics of the main universe
venom now moving on to the offspring of
venom the first and most prominent is of
course
carnage which was created by david
miccolini and mark bagley and first
appeared in amazing spider-man number
361 in 1992. now the carnos symbiote was
created when eddie brock who was bonded
with the venom symbiote at the time
escaped from prison and unbeknownst to
eddie left an offspring behind that
would bond with a cellmate a maniacal
serial killer named cletus cassidy now
cassidy would be the most frequent host
of the carnage symbiote whose abilities
differ significantly from the venom
symbiote because carnage was born into
an environment
alien to its species the environment of
earth and so the carnage symbiote
strength surpasses that of venom
and it also possesses advanced
shape-shifting abilities allowing its
hosts to turn
appendages into weapons and can even
fire projectile weapons made of the
symbiote itself
the symbiote's tendrils can implant
thoughts in the minds of others and can
also relay information it perceives
from any direction to its host
instantaneously the symbiote grants its
host a regenerative healing factor and
like venom is undetectable by peter
parker's spider sense and it's highly
adaptive to its environment for example
evolving to allow its hosts to breathe
in space now when the codex or the
genetic imprint of the carnage symbiote
reacted with the grendel symbiote when
it reanimated cletus cassidy's corpse
the result was a far more powerful
entity than carnage had ever been before
and it also gained the ability to create
brain worms which you can use to infect
others and turn them into copies of
carnage now in the 1993 mini-series
venom lethal protector by david mcelini
mark bagley and ron lim we see the
introduction
of five more symbiotes scream riot phage
lasher
and agony now the story here centers
around a group called the life
foundation
dedicated to ensuring the survival of
the country's wealthiest citizens in the
event of an apocalypse type
event now when venom interferes with one
of their plans they extract part of the
venom symbiote and choose five of the
life foundation security guards
these five symbiotes seem to have
basically the same powers as venom but
also seem to be slightly less powerful
eventually scream murders her four
siblings but only the host
dies while the other symbiotes are taken
to the vault super prison
and merged into one symbiote known as
hybrid and venom along famous fighter
number one by larry hama and joe
saint-pierre now the symbiotes were
subjected to extremely painful
experiments and once vault guard scott
washington discovers this he releases
them from their confinement and all four
bond with him now due to the
experimentation by the government these
symbiotes gain some unique abilities
such as heightened senses in the case of
phage lasher's ability to bond with
animals
riot's ability to move faster than the
naked eye can detect and agony's ability
to increase its host musculature and
spit acid
and so when scott washington became
hybrid he gained
all of these powers as well as the
standard symbiote powers but venom
is not the only symbiote to produce
offspring as carnage has produced some
itself the first of which
is toxin so toxin was created by peter
milligan and clayton crane
and first appeared in venom carnage
number two in 2004.
now when carnage found out that he was
about to reproduce he began
fostering a deep-seated hatred for his
eventual offspring
fearing that it may become more powerful
than himself and so he decides to kill
it as soon as it's born now venom tries
to talk him out of this of course it
doesn't work because carnage is insane
so venom tries to protect the new
symbiote as he also fears that it will
be the symbiote that may become unstable
due to being the 1000th generation of
their race and so to hide the symbiote
from venom
carnage gives birth to it and then bonds
it with a new york city police officer
named patrick mulligan
and attempts to kill both of them but of
course he's stopped by venom now once
venom realizes how strong the toxin
symbiote will become
he decides carnage is right and helps
him try to kill it but toxin is aided in
battle by spider-man when they defeat
venom
and carnage now toxin has all the venom
and carnage abilities and is physically
stronger than either of them and also
possesses an ability to track any other
individual
an expansion of the ability that most
symbiotes have to track other symbiotes
or their hosts now the next symbiote
that we're introduced to
is actually not a true symbiote but it's
part of a race known as the variance
which are a genetically similar offshoot
to the klyntar race
now trent who is an agent of shield is
approached by a symbiote called payback
that had previously bonded to his father
the payback symbiote differed from the
venom symbiote and his progeny in a
variety of ways
first it fed off the bliss of its host
and was more of an entity made of energy
instead of organic matter in addition to
enhanced physical attributes and a
healing factor the payback symbiote
allows its hosts to fly and project
electromagnetic energy
of course being pure energy the payback
symbiote has a vulnerability to water
and coming into contact with water will
result in accidental expulsions of
electricity
next up we have anti-venom created by
dan slott and john romita jr and making
his debut
an amazing spider-man number 569 and
2008. now eddie brock is working at a
soup kitchen run by martin lee the
supervillain known as mr negative
lee cures eddie of his cancer using his
ability to control light force energy
and shortly thereafter eddie is attacked
by matt gargan who was bonded to venom
at the time
the venom symbiote tries to rebond with
eddie but touching eddie's skin
harms venom and parts of the symbiote
merge with the antibodies created by the
light force energy to create a holy new
symbiote known as antivenom now the
anti-venom symbiote has all the
abilities of venom but does not possess
its weaknesses to sound
and fire the symbiote is able to heal
others from a variety of afflictions
through its ability to produce
antibodies but using this ability
drains anti-venom's powers furthermore
anti-venom does display a weakness to
dark force energy which is the dark
counterpart to the light force energy
that led to its creation now this brings
us to a weird one
the mutant symbiote known as zisks
zx it's it's literally zzzxx i don't
know how to pronounce that six
six i have no idea we're just gonna call
it z created by chris yoss and dustin
weaver z
first appeared in x-men king breaker
number two in 2009. now z
was a symbiote discovered by the shia
empire unlike any they had ever seen
before
as it actually fed on the brains of its
host now z was locked away for years as
one of the five most dangerous criminals
the shiar had ever encountered but
vulcan
the brother of scott and alex summers
chose to be part of his imperial guard
and bonded him to a shiar soldier before
bonding to the starjammer raza long
knife and eventually
the cancerverse version of charles
xavier which was basically just a giant
brain for z to feed on that's really all
it was other than the bit about eating
the brains of its hosts
z seems to have pretty much the same
powers as other symbiotes
then we have the second offspring of
carnage which is known as
scorn which was created by zeb wells and
clayton crane and first appeared in
carnage number four in 2011 and so at
this point
carnage was ripped in half by the
century and left to float through the
endlessness of space but it actually
survived the experience
and returned to earth now a man named
michael hall discovers carnage and tries
to use it to create artificial limbs but
when a doctor named tanis knees loses
his arm she gets one of these
prosthetics to replace it and as you may
have guessed
the results are disastrous as she is
unable to control the symbiote which
kills several people as it bonds to her
now when the carnage symbiote finds
cletus cassidy
it leaves tannis but leaves behind an
offspring that bonds with tanus turning
her
into scorn a hybrid symbiote cyborg now
the main distinction between scorn and
other symbiotes is that she can bond
herself to technology
due to her techno-organic physiology
she's also able to communicate with and
control various types of technology
and can change herself into any form of
technology that she comes into contact
with now carnage's offspring do not stop
there however
as during jerry conway's run on carnage
in 2016
an fbi agent named claire dixon is
captured by carnage and used in a ritual
whereby he tries to bolster his power
using a book called the darkhold the
result is that claire is turned into a
symbiote known as reyes who seems to
have no powers
beyond those common to all symbiotes and
finally we come to sleeper now sleeper
was created by mike costa and mark
bagley and first appeared in venom
number 165 in 2018
the final issue of venom before the
current donnie kate's run began
now claire dixon who we just discussed
was thought to be dead but as it turns
out due to her exposure to the darkhold
she couldn't actually die
anyway she captures eddie brock and
tells him that the venom symbiote is
about to give birth
eddie escapes and finds a doctor to help
deliver the spawn
a process that's difficult for the venom
symbiote and despite an attempt by
scorpion to steal the spawn as it was
born it's successfully delivered
and kept in the care of alcomax now this
offspring would become known as sleeper
and was stolen
by telcar the first host of venom after
the venom symbiote refused to bond with
him once more and so before telcar could
bond with sleeper the symbiote
bonded with eddie the sleeper would
later lobotomize telcar
and use his body to explore space where
he learned about null and came back to
earth to protect eddie
and his son dylan now in addition to the
normal symbiote powers sleeper
has displayed an ability to become
invisible and to produce a variety of
chemicals and pheromones to produce a
wide variety of effects
including manipulating the thoughts and
emotions of others and so
that's pretty much the most major
symbiotes in the marvel universe
i'm not gonna say all because there may
have been a couple that slipped through
the cracks i don't think they are
i think for the most part we pretty much
caught them all uh but i'm sure you'll
let me know in the comments
if i did forget a few so with that being
said if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
corp if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign